thank you for joining us for the press
conference following the eu china
leaders meeting
we're joined remotely by the chancellor
of germany in berlin
field command from bundeslin let me
first state
that we provide translation in french
english chinese and german
and we'll take some questions of course
from berlin and here in brussels
but first i give the floor to the
council president
good afternoon angela and good afternoon
everyone
i am pleased that we could speed by
video conference with president xi
together with ursula and angela
unfortunately
our physical meeting in leipzig wasn't
possible
europe needs to be a player not a
playing field
today's meeting represents another step
forward
in forging a more balanced relationship
with china
we strive for relationship that delivers
on our mutual commitments
that generates concrete results for both
sides
results that are also good for the world
in some areas we are on the right
stretch
and in others more work needs to be done
we made it clear where we stand where we
agree
and where we disagree real differences
exist
and we want paper over them but you are
ready to engage
ready to cooperate where we can't and
ready to all up our sleeves
to find concrete solutions and on those
difficult issues
we conveyed a clear and united european
message
we want a relationship with china that's
based
on reciprocity responsibility
and basic fairness today we addressed
four key topics climate change
economic trade economic and trade issues
international affairs and human rights
covet 19
and economic recovery china
is a key global partner in reducing
global greenhouse gas
and tackling climate change and we
encourage
china to be even more ambitious
the eu is setting the bar high
carbon neutrality by 2050 and we count
on china
to show similar leadership by
implementing the paris agreement
angela will say more about this
we have a robust trading relationship
with china
the eu is china's first trading partner
on average we trade over 1 billion euros
a day
and to it can energize our economic
recovery
but we want more fairness
we want a more balanced relationship
that
also means reciprocity and
a level playing field that's why we
welcome to the signature
of the agreement on geographical
indications it's a big step
in the right direction we are working
on a comprehensive investment agreement
and concrete results
in other important areas ursula will say
more about that and in the digital
domain
we defend our vision of a free
open and secure cyberspace
for the good of our people and of our
societies
as global players the eu
and china have global responsibilities
this means upholding the rules-based
international order
the national security law for hong kong
continues to raise grave concerns
the eu and our member states have
responded
with one clear voice democratic voices
in hong kong should be hurt rights
protected and autonomy preserved
we called on china to keep their
promises to the people of hong kong
and the international community we
reiterated
our concerns over china's treatment of
minorities
in xinjiang and tibet and the treatment
of human rights defenders and
journalists
we asked for access for independent
observers
to changing and we called for the
release
of the arbitrarily detained swedish
citizen minhai and two canadian citizens
we agreed to discuss these issues in
details at the human rights dialogue
in being later this year which will also
include
we hope a field visit to tibet
we called on china to refrain from
unilateral actions in the south china
sea
to respect international law and avoid
escalations
profit 19 we miss a deep and
urgent threat only collective
and transparent action will send this
virus to the history books
there is only one way to find a vaccine
and deploy it in all countries
and that's global cooperation
we expect all countries to cooperate
with the impartial
independent and comprehensive evaluation
of the international health response to
javit 19
and support the who to identify
the source of the virus we entered
china to pursue an economic recovery
that leads
to structural reforms and it shapes a
greener
more sustainable economy and this
includes
implementing the g20 action plan to
drive sustainable global growth
and reduce global tensions and
in africa china should be engaged
in multilateral efforts on debt relief
that will spur
economic recovery in conclusion
no distribution
extremely important
[Music]
and now we're going to switch to berlin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
passing the floor now to madam president
please yes thank you so much indeed it
was a frank an open
and a constructive and intense uh
quattro log that we had today i was
about to say dialogue but
this is not the case so
and i it was a broad spectrum of topics
indeed from human rights to climate to
digital
to trade and i want to focus on the
trade
part indeed as we committed to at the
summit in june
we have stepped up our engagement at the
political level
over the past weeks notably in the areas
of trade
climate and digital and
here i want to start with in the trader
agenda with the comprehensive
agreement on investment
last time last summer two months ago i
stressed to president xi that the
european union
remains committed to a genuine
result-oriented
engagement and progress we need concrete
results
and now we have agreement amongst
negotiation negotiations on three
important issues
first of all on the disciplines
regarding the behavior of
state-owned enterprises then on forced
technology transfer and on
transparency on subsidies this is an
important part an important step forward
however i want to caution that
a lot a lot still remains to be done in
other important and difficult chapters
of the agreement
particularly into two areas the one is
market access
and the other one is sustainable
development
we expect that the market access
barriers
in china will be removed especially
for future and emerging digital
technologies they are the core of our
economies it's telecommunication it's
computer sectors
it's health biotechnology and the new
energy vehicles and transport
we see that our investors just face too
many barriers in these key
sectors and for us with
market access it's not a question of
meeting halfway
but it's a question of rebalancing the
asymmetry and
a question of openness of our respective
markets
so we need china to move on these two
issues and
we needed to move if we are to achieve
to achieve our shared objective of
finalizing negotiations
this year so in other words china has to
convince
us that it is worth having an investment
agreement
the second topic wasn't is a chinese
over capacity
it's also a serious issue for us both in
traditional sectors like steel and
aluminium
but also in high tech there are so far
unfortunately no concrete steps forward
so this needs to change and we addressed
it very clearly
joining the global forum on steel access
capacity and
eliminating the state subsidies that
contribute to this over capacity
would be necessary steps in this regard
and i've agreed with president xi to
follow up on this
bilaterally we also
reiterated to president xi that china
had
committed to extending to eu businesses
the favorable treatment granted to
us operators under the u.s china trade
deal agreed in
january and we expect this commitment
to be met now what the digital is
concerned
first of all the european union welcomes
that
china reaffirmed its commitment to a
human-centric approach to ai
and welcomes that work on this will be
carried forward
in the g20 here too we hope
to see concrete progress in this context
we reaffirmed the importance of market
access also here for goods and services
in the area of telecommunications
the european market is open and european
companies must have
fair and equal access to the chinese
market
in return we took note of president xi's
commitment
to look into these matters
at the same time the european union will
continue to stress
the importance of its networks being
secure
and in this overall context of all these
different
topics concerning the digital agenda we
have together
i very much welcome that we had the
first ever
high-level digital dialogue which took
place last week
so we agreed with president xi that we
will continue and broaden this dialogue
what the
scope and the topics are concerned
finally on the wto reform
china has repeatedly stated that it is
committed
to the wto that also requires that china
negotiates to strengthen existing rules
on industrial subsidies in the context
of the world trade
organization's reform and in line
with the summit commitment it made in
2019 this was a topic too
last but not least we had a brief
exchange
on corona virus pandemic the pandemic
we're all facing we discussed the need
to continue to act in global solidarity
and cooperation in this matter
it is very important to engage in the
global framework
not only to find a vaccine but also to
make it accessible to low and medium
income countries
as you know we've set up a whole global
framework
to ensure that and we invited china to
join
this covex facility it is important
also to continue understanding the
origins of the pandemic and therefore
we were very clear that it is very
important to give
the who all the possibilities to have
to lead its investigations on the origin
of covet 19 to be
successful in summer very concrete
meeting
with tangible actions discussed
thank you madam president for your
remarks we'll uh now take
a couple of questions here in brussels
first and since this is a virtual press
conference please
please bear with us may i ask you to
stick to one
question for journalists and clearly
state um
to whom you want to address your
question to i'm going to start first
with marcus price from aarde marcus can
you hear us
yes i can yeah yumi as well yes please
ask your question oh my question goes to
chancellor merkel
and so if i may i would like to ask in
uh in german um
thank you
next question is for stuart lau
stuart can you hear us
yes thank you very much um i also have a
question for madam chancellor your
supporters call you the western leader
who knows chinese leadership thinking
the best
but on the other hand your critics say
germany's strong trading interest
empowers china not just economically but
also geopolitically
and it is now competing with european
technology and promoting political views
alternative to western values looking
back at the
last 15 years and looking at china today
do you think your approach succeeded or
would you have done things differently
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you staying in berlin for a next
round of questions
passing flow to my colleagues
um
[Music]
uh
lanka continuing further on in berlin
andreas from reuters
[Music]
thank you we're continuing the press
conference here in brussels and i'm
going to take two more questions
i'm first going to start with angela
mauro from the huffington post
angela can you hear us yes i can hear
you can you hear me
yes please okay i um
hello and thanks for the opportunity i
have a question for chancellor merkel
if she can elaborate more on the climate
part of the deal
uh did you discuss a hypothetical
deadline for china to become a neutral
country
for the emissions i mean for the eu is
2050.
before the meeting they told us that was
this hypothetical deadline
uh on 2016 for china to respect
these goals is this uh realistic like
the line
thank you
thank you we're going to go to
madame president again because i forgot
you
your question was addressed to you as
well on the investment agreement
and you wanted to add a couple of
remarks i suppose yeah well
uh indeed um so what the investment
agreement is concerned and the timeline
of potentially
having it as an agreement that we can
sign at the end of the year
uh indeed um we started
well let's let's put it the other way
when we had the summit in
june uh 2020 up to then
almost no progress was seen and
the negotiations team only did not come
on a high political level
so we were very clear in june
that there would be no investment
agreement if we do not see substantial
progress and we have seen a reaction
that is positive
so now it's a high level negotiation
team
that is sitting on that topic
and we've seen the progress i told you
about
the fields where we are advancing now
but i must say there is still a lot to
do
so on the market access for example the
telecom and computer services
there are these famous joint venture and
equity caps
restrictions that have to be lifted same
goes for the automotive sector for
example
that here also the economic needs tests
need to be lifted just to name two but
it shows to you
that we are really serious about having
access to the chinese market and to tear
down
the barriers same goes for the uh
sustainable development so
we we need here progress of course on
the chinese side there are also demands
but as i've said it is now uh the time
to prove
that there's a real interest to step up
to change
things for the better then there is the
possibility to have this
investment agreement so it's not a
matter of time but it's a matter of
substance now
thank you madam president going to take
a last question now from david carretta
radio radically david
italian
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the situation the perimeter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and with these final remarks this
concludes our press conference
thank you all for joining and see you
soon
[Music]
you